well
no
god
no god please no no
no
no what's up everybody welcome back to
the cosmic wonder i'm your host warren
thompson and sadly it is looking like we
are not going to be getting that
spider-man no way home trailer 2 on
october 25th but the good news is is it
now looks like we do have a pretty good
window of when to really expect it and
before a lot of people start thinking
that spider-man no way home might be
delayed or it is delayed because of this
that is not the case so you don't need
to worry that much and it does look like
the trailer still is only a few weeks
away
i'll break down everything that you need
to know about the trailer in this video
and don't forget we are still doing our
giveaway our spider-man figurine
giveaway all you gotta do to enter
subscribe to my channel and subscribe to
my other channel that chris runs cosmic
culture so let's get right to the point
no need to drag this out it's looking
like spider-man no way home it's second
trailer is no longer going to be
releasing on the 25th originally it
seemed like that was a pretty solid date
daniel richman who has been insanely
accurate on when trailers are going to
be coming out said that we could expect
it at the end of october or the
beginning of november then another
source came out and said october 25th
which is the end of october so that was
in line with what daniel richmond said
however daniel richmond came out today
on twitter and stated that the trailer
is not coming on the 25th he stated that
he has heard that the trailer is two to
three weeks away from where we are right
now now this falls in line with what he
said before late october or early
november early november is looking to be
two to three weeks away which would
still give us time about a month before
spider-man no way home actually hits
theaters now like i mentioned in the
beginning of the video some people are
now saying that the film is delayed
because the trailer isn't coming when we
expected it to on october 25th but this
is not the case and daniel even spoke up
on his other twitter account saying that
he never said it was delayed but the
trailer is not coming for at least two
to three more weeks that's what i meant
and that's what he said on twitter and
again daniel is very accurate when it
comes to trailer release dates in fact
he was accurate about the first
spider-man no way home trailer when he
found out about it the thing to keep in
mind here is that the studio may not
have ever set a release date for the
trailer on october 25th this report
stating that it's not coming for another
two to three more weeks does not mean
that they are moving the trailer back
from a release date that they already
had planned heck sony might not even
have an official release date planned
yet but more like a window when they
want to release it but the good news is
that as of right now spider-man no way
home is not delayed and a few days ago
marvel came out and delayed a lot of
their films but spider-man no way home
was not one of them this is a really
really good sign and now we're less than
two months away before we see spider-man
knowing home in theater so we're almost
there now i will say that the marketing
and advertising for spider-man netway
home has been very very different than
anything that we've seen before heck
releasing the second trailer only about
a month before the actual movie comes
out is kind of weird but i definitely
think sony knows what's up they know
everybody is talking about it and the
hype is very very real and the good news
is we are actually getting a second
trailer because we were kind of
wondering if we were even going to get
one trailer at first but right now
everything points to us getting a second
trailer for spider-man no way home in
about two to three weeks so hang tight
and of course if you want to stay up to
date on spider-man knowing home
including when the second trailer could
be coming out be sure to subscribe and
hit that notification bell so you don't
miss out on any of the latest videos
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter i usually post on
there first before doing videos as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof